we repeatedly given messages that we
live in sexually enlightened times that
we belong to a liberated age and
therefore the implication is that we
ought by now to be finding sex as
straightforward a nun troubling matter
we are not after all Victorians or
prudes the standard narrative of our
release from past inhibitions goes
something like this the thousands of
years right across the globe due to a
devilish combination of religious
bigotry and pedantic social customs
people were afflicted by a ridiculous
sense of confusion and guilt around sex
they thought their hands would fall off
if they masturbated they believed they
might be burnt in a vat of oil because
they'd agel someone's ankle they had no
clue about erections or clitoris
they were seen then sometime between the
first world war and the launch of
Sputnik one things changed for the
better finally people started wearing
bikinis admitted to masturbating through
able to mention cunnilingus in social
context started to watch porn films and
became deeply comfortable with a topic
which had almost unaccountably been a
source of needless chaotic frustration
for most of human history it seems
almost inconceivable now how hung up our
ancestors had been sex came to be
perceived as a useful refreshing and
physically reviving pastime a bit like
tennis the one that could sit perfectly
well within the context of bourgeois
family life as the kids were in bed this
narrative of enlightenment and progress
however flattering it may be to the
modern age conveniently skirts an
unbuttoned fact we remain hugely
conflicted embarrassed ashamed and odd
about sex sex refuses to match up simply
with love and remains as difficult to
subject as ever with one added
complication it's meant to be so simple
in reality none of us approaches sex as
we meant to with a cheerful sporting non
obsessive clean loyal well-adjusted
outlook that we convinced ourselves is
the norm we are universally order around
sex but only in relation to some highly
and cruelly distorted ideals of
normality
most of what we are sexually remains
very frightening to communicates to
anyone whom we would want to think well
of us people in love constantly
instinctively hold back from sharing
more than a fraction of their desires
and tastes out of a fear not without
foundation of generating intolerable
disgust in their partners in the choice
between being laughed and being honest
most of us choose the former but we are
then burdened by a sexuality which
refuses to stop haunting us we suffer
and yet may find it easier to die
without having had certain conversations
the priority seems evident to find a way
to talk to ourselves and our partners
about who we really are to tell one
another without setting off catastrophic
panic offense or fear what sex really
makes us want it maybe someone else saw
them in a uniform at the heart of the
dilemma is how simile to appear normal
and yet achieve honesty about our sexual
appetites our commitment to feeling
normal is important and touching it
means being or at least trying very hard
to be patient gentle considerate
democratic intelligent and devoted to
treating people with respect and loyalty
and yet our sexual imaginations simply
refuse to bow to any normative
parameters to start the list here are
just some of the unpalatable truths that
stir essential imaginations it's very
rare to maintain sexual interest in only
one person however much one loves them
beyond more than a few years it's
entirely possible to love one's partner
and regularly want to have sex with
complete strangers one can be a kind
respectable and democratic person and at
the same time want a flogged hurt and
humiliate a sexual partner will be on
the receiving end of very rough
treatment it may be easier to be excited
by someone want dislikes or thinks
nothing of than by someone one loves and
respects though we may try to tame them
our sexual desires remain often an
absurd irreconcilable conflict with many
of our highest commitments and values we
need to admit to ourselves that whatever
the self-congratulation sexual
liberation has never in fact happened
this is about more than the ability to
wear a bikini
we remain imprisoned fearful and ashamed
sometimes with few options but to lie
for the sake of love the true liberation
is a challenge that remains before us as
we patiently build up the courage to
admit to the nature of our desires and
learn to talk to our loved ones with
pioneering honesty about the contents of
our own minds
you